[Applause]
your baby's beautiful
thank you she's just pays for it she's a
cute kid i got a cute kid thank god my
baby's not a dog show thank god thank
god and she's got two eyes because now
he only has one eye so we're nervous
yeah and my only child
she's got two separated beautiful eyes
she looks like your wife thank god
yes because i mean what would you do if
your baby came out look like maurice i
think i'm yeah
i might have to just try to shove it
back up there and say yeah
thank god my only job i think is to hug
my baby little girl just as many times
as i can so she doesn't come out
you're i don't know no because it's a
joke
honestly let me give you some fatherly
advice yeah i'm doing the opposite i'm
hoping and praying my kid's a fat
lesbian
because it's just as a father it just
takes a little pressure off if she's
just fat and just goes a little gay yeah
you don't got to worry about some you
know [ __ ] guy coming in
like and just gonna you know treat her
like [ __ ] so i think you want to go fat
like
i know i'm just i'm saying that was a
joke i want my baby to be whatever
the first thing we're going to do is sit
her down tell her about tolerance and
tell her yeah her to choose it's up to
her i support it it's just
i put myself on notice for saying that
i apologize perfect segway appearance
i'm sorry
did you watch the unnoticed boys video
alex no i didn't he's too [ __ ] busy
schultz's got him editing five things
[Music]
it was there i'm glad you said it and i
mean the joke was there
so you know the time is marked the
joker's there
sorry i was not i was gonna tell you i'm
just no the joke was there
yeah you could do it yeah
we're comedians i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry i love you aoc
yeah so the unnoticed boys
so the unnoticed boys is it's a backlash
against
pc culture right it is and it isn't it's
just we're making a joke
at one side we'll also come out with a
sketch next week that's
making fun of the other side
we're not like we're just being silly
but the problem is is when we've made
plenty of jokes
about the other side there's no backlash
it's just either like it or don't like
it
any time you attack that sign it's all
backlash if you don't like it they can't
just keep their mouth shut where it's
like either favorite it and like it or
move on yeah
that side you're talking about people
who want politically correct things yeah
yes like they have to cro
what do you the whole country wasn't
boarded up i'm not because of trump
supporters
i'm going to push back a little bit
because i've no i used to love
republican audiences yeah they didn't
give a [ __ ] just don't talk about jesus
that's easy for me i'm religious i'll
respect your
respect your religion we're good you
don't know about jesus you're good
now anything you say anything that they
perceive as anti-trump
[ __ ] this guy he doesn't know anything
he's so stupid trump has actually
created some right-wing snowflakes too
that's true as he is on twitter and as
funny as it is when he shits on
pc culture he also has created some
snowflake culture
you want a moderate audience having them
the centrist that's the best
the best best on itself which i
genuinely believe
makes up the majority of our country
country yeah i think the majority of our
country down the middle
like you know we're all down i mean
yanny's liberal but he has a gun
you know like i'm i'm i'm more i'm more
conservative but
you know i believe that there should be
tighter border security it's like so
i got a [ __ ] you know i got a house
and a kid but you know i believe in a
woman's right to choose
i think i don't want children in cages
you know but it's like listen if you
don't got your right papers you got to
get thrown over the wall
that's just what it is you know and
yani's a snowflake with a shotgun
but he's got property yeah everyone's
trying to put us into these model lists
and see these groups
we're all complicated people that have
opinions that run the gamut you know i
think as a comedian
i think for me in our podcast history
hyenas
um hyenas
bay ridge hyenas patreon.com rich boys
yep we're either trying to
make you laugh no matter what you
believe or we're trying to piss you off
for the right reasons
yeah i mean yeah pissing someone off for
the right reasons is
a lot of times just as fulfilling as
making them laugh
the on notice boy sketch if you guys
watch it if you check it out it's not
even
there's a moment i'm sorry i didn't know
but there's a moment where giannis i'm
not giving anything away but he killed
him
holy f i saw chris almost break that
made me laugh harder yeah
that [ __ ] killed me fa you saw it yeah
yeah
okay i saw it i saw it three times yeah
i saw it free it was three minutes and i
saw it for free
three times thanks thanks
yeah so what kind of [ __ ] shoes are
you wearing guy i mean those things are
wild
they look like whipped cream these are
the studio shoes andrew bought a pair
for everybody
oh god okay so the fur ball looks like a
baby's [ __ ] winter jacket on his foot
so but with the aoc sketch all we were
trying to point out is
we have no problem with aoc or the we're
just like silly we understand
some good things are bad you know what
like we said we understand both sides we
understand both sides but the thing that
we're making fun of which was scary
is that she tweeted out that any trump
cincto fan any that we were going to be
on some kind
of thing yes that's what it is sickle
family sick
is what he's trying to say yeah any any
any trump got a doctorate in physical
therapy but here's the thing about a
physical therapy doctorate
you don't really got to learn how to
read you know how to massage people no
it's what it is yeah i just get in there
it's just about making them come so so
i i that the sketch was about just
calling that lunacy out how anybody
would be on a list
because of something they tweeted when
the whole point of america is now
freedom of speech and be in democracy
and agree to disagree
so we just thought that tweet was wild
so we went off that it's
if you're gonna just write off almost
half the country that's insane
for any one reason yeah that's insane
yeah
and i think you got to understand some
people might not be extreme right and
they still voted for the guy
why instead of saying [ __ ] you hey maybe
if you ask why you voted that way
and then i understand you and then i'm
like all right but here's my point of
view look we can actually meet somewhere
in the middle one
i bet you one of the because some
members of my family did this one of
their
amazing people one issue voters yeah one
issue well just how the republicans and
democrats have chose
you know either the pro-choice pro-life
religion thing that makes people
have to choose like people in my family
are very catholic very religious great
people
they believe in the they believe that a
baby's a miracle and you can't kill a
life so they will always vote republican
always
just because of pro-choice yeah so it's
like does that make them a horrible
person
yeah no but there should be a separation
of church and state so that's what i'm
saying there should be people there's
way
yeah it's not a religion it's more of a
but it's like that ties back into
chris's point that not everybody should
be able to vote
i think yeah i think yeah i understand
you're religious any one issue that
trumps everything else
probably yeah i don't think i should be
able to you made a good point though
dude it's like
yeah i mean we go the the left has
become uh
such an easy target because there's so a
lot of the far left is kind of hijacking
them a little bit they've gotten so zany
yeah but the right is still there's
still meat on that bone because
those [ __ ] will believe
anything true
you get on the internet and you're like
hey you're like hey there's kids
i saw some kids getting touched in the
basement of a walmart at 23rd and 2nd
there's like 15 guys going to show up
in military garbage shotgun saying
where's [ __ ] hillary clinton
how did she turn into a demon and how
she [ __ ] kissed there's still to this
day people that think hillary clinton
like flavors are pepsi with a board of
fetuses yeah i mean you get a [ __ ]
parking ticket they're like george soros
did this
george soros is like the [ __ ]
all-knowing evil devil
let me ask you guys a question i think
and i've said this before i think how to
get more political akash
i think i don't i don't know anything i
didn't even know every state got two
sentences
yeah uh here's what i think i think rush
limbaugh said this politics is not a
spectrum it's a circle
and the extremes are the same and
tell me if i'm wrong i think it's almost
like you know how kids
like don't feel like they belong
anywhere and sometimes that's how they
fall into a gang like they just feel
love from this group of people so that's
their family
do you think it's the same thing
politically like what makes a person go
extreme one way or the other i think
there's a little bit of like yeah a
little comfort in the group for sure
it's like a group hey i belong somewhere
yeah come from yeah it's the same i
think for
when like a whop a woke mob comes after
you i think if they didn't know that
there was
others backing them up when those pylons
happen online
yeah they wouldn't do it they would be
quiet they'd be scared to go at you
if they didn't know that they had like a
whole group that would also pile on and
like it and retweet yeah i mean we're
we're
our species is [ __ ] yeah we're sure
while it's based in tribalism our
species that's that's the whole point of
surviving
there's a tribe and people always want
to go right to oh that's race there's no
it's not about race it's about like what
you said like you find your tribe you
find the woke tribe
or you find the conservative tribe or
sometimes people do it on race or teams
well the freedom of being a minority is
my tribe is right there i don't have to
look for it
that's what you're talking about not in
pakistan for sure absolutely not you
know
when you said right there you should be
pointing they want a space for their own
tribe
how's that going guys anyway i think
it's easy if you're a minority in the
sense that like oh this is my tribe i'm
with them let's roll
whereas for a white straight guy in
america there is
no hey this is what your identity is i
remember andrew as a comic would always
be like
what do i open with i don't know how the
[ __ ] to open right to address the
audience hey this is who i am
for me i looked up we went back and like
studied old comics every minority comic
from chappelle
brewer barnes like i looked at special
after special after special like patrice
i think
they pretty much always open with in
some way i am this race
let's acknowledge that i'm different
than most people the majority of the
country that's it
why people don't have that thing to just
latch onto yeah so i think you guys
are more it's easier for you guys to
fall into political extremes because
it's like oh that's something i can
latch onto
you